ce sera dans quelques instants on
jacques et jean marc jancovici merci de
nous avoir rejoint jean marc jancovici
vous êtes ingénieur consultant en
énergie président du think tank de shift
project qui formule en fait des
propositions pour réaliser très
concrètement l'accord de paris et puis
vous venez d'être nommé au conseil sur
le climat je rappelle votre dernier
livre l'avenir climatique quels temps
fort on ou aux éditions du seuil
il va servir à quoi ce comité que vous
rejoignez vous l'avez compris je crois
[Rires]
alors je peux déjà vous dire à quoi il
ne va pas servir ça n'est pas une
réponse au mouvement des gilets jaunes
parce qu'il va s'inscrire dans un temps
assez long qui n'est pas du tout celui
de la réponse immédiate qui est
aujourd'hui formulées dans la rue quelle
que soit cette demande soit dit en
passant parce que je pense qu'il est
assez protéiforme et pas nécessairement
très simple à comprendre
le ça ne concerne pas les gilet jaune
alors ça le concerne indirectement dans
la durée pas directement tout de suite
oui parce qu'un prochaine ce que ça
concerne c'est que c'est un ces 13
personnes dont condé pas superstitieux
qui vont formuler à intervalles
réguliers mais pas toutes les semaines
un avis sur la politique publique en
matière de trajectoire sur les émissions
si je dis simplement
donc en gros qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
faire baisser les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de la france alors là où
c'est un lien direct avec le sujet gilet
jaune c'est que les deux tiers du co2
français viennent du pétrole et que dans
le pétrole une grosse moitié vient des
transports terrestres donc c'est un peu
compliqué de faire respecter les accords
de paris sans s'occuper à un moment ou à
un autre du pétrole pompé dans les
voitures le propos est temps aussi de
faire respecter l'accord de paris bien
sûr voilà l'envié parce que c'est alors
noyau zenadi comité théodule et c'est
donc ça sera peut-être un comité
théodule on verra ensuite interdit le
rsa peut être pu jouer quand vous
démarrez votre émission ne sait pas
encore exactement que ça vous emmènera
six mois puis donc de rodez mars et une
expérience une expérience intéressante
et s'est inspiré du climate change
committee anglais est du reste la
présidente du haut conseil pour le
climat et membre du climate change
committee anglais donc on a anticipé le
break site on a refait un lien ça y est
directement ses biens propres excite
mais ce qui est très bien parce qu'elle
a une expérience pratique du
fonctionnement de ce genre de choses
vous allez être un tableau de bord
pardonnez moi de vous bousculer mais
qu'on voit on va on va alors je sais que
les journalistes aiment bien bousculer
jeu on va surtout devoir dire ce qu'on
est capable de faire et de ne pas faire
avec 24 heures par jour 13 membres du
comité qui ont une activité par ailleurs
donc on verra ce qu'on arrive à faire on
va avoir des moyens qui seront pas juste
nos cervelles
il va falloir qu'on a une équipe on
verra alors exactement ce qu'on leur
demande de chercher et ce qui est ce que
le propos de ce haut conseil sur le
climat et d'orienter notre politique et
notre transition oui écologique et
énergétique vous donnés je peux vous
donner deux exemples parfaits je ne vais
pas vous dire ce que pensent leurs
conseils je vais vous donner deux
exemples de sujets qui pourraient par
exemple tombé dans cette escarcelle
absolument ya en ce moment une loi sur
les mobilités qui est discuté à
l'assemblée nationale
la mobilité c'est du pétrole on pourrait
très bien émettre un avis intègre enfin
sur la pertinence intégrant la
pertinence de cette loi est ce que elle
est adaptée est ce qu'on essaye de
résoudre un prêt qui vaut mille avec une
solution qui vaut 1 où est ce que la
solution mobile ou est ce qu'elle vous
disais ce qu'elle vaut sans répondant à
des questions concrètes du style bah oui
c'est peut-être pas mal de mettre des
vignettes sur les sur les camions on
verra je là là là vous êtes on arrive on
est vraiment aux prémices c'est à dire
que pour rien caché à personne moi j'ai
appris que j'allais faire partie de
cette instance mercredi soir de la
semaine dernière j'ai appris qu'ils
seraient quelle serait la liste complète
des participants
hier donc on est on découvre d'accord
oui bien sûr la règle dans la pièce avec
vous ça sent la peinture fraîche voilà
et on va voir quel genre de discussions
ce qui est intéressant je le redis c'est
que ça s'inscrit dans le temps long donc
a priori on a au moins signé pour cinq
ans et c'est pas quelque chose qui vise
alors je pense qu'il ya eu une petite je
sais pas si je dois dire erreur de
calendrier à parler à la fois de la
concertation avec les gilets jaunes et
de l'installation de ce haut conseil
sens bien précise et l'articulation
entre les deux ce que je ne crois pas
avoir entendu dans le discours
présidentiel donnant un belge était met
donc la cia il ya peut-être une un peu
de pédagogie qui a manqué sur
l'articulation entre les deux le lien
encore une fois est évident parce que le
pétrole c'est l'essentiel du co2
français mais mais les deux sont pas
dans le même temps bon le co2 faut s'en
passer moi je vous pose la question
alors de toute façon on va devoir
je rappelle qu'il faut 100 millions
d'années pour faire du pétrole et donc
le pétrole n'est pas renouvelable et que
les mathématiques nous impose quand on
tape dans quelque chose de pas renouvelé
que la consommation fait ça d'accord ça
peut pas faire autre chose et en fait
depuis 2006 ça passe sous l'écran radar
de la majeure partie de vos confrères
mais depuis 2006 la quantité de pétrole
que les européens peuvent consommer
c'est à dire la somme de ce qui vient de
la mer du nord qui est notre seule
production domestique et de ce qu'on
importe a baissé de plus de 10%
ça avait même baissé de 16 % en 2014
c'est un peu remonté grâce aux chez
l'ogre américain
donc on est déjà en décrue pétrolière
subi est en fait les gilet jaune en sont
une des manifestations pour moi en 2011
j'avais écrit dans les échos une tribune
qui s'appelait marine le pen enfants du
carbone où j'expliquais que si on
décarbonés pas volontairement l'économie
l'économiste décarboner est tout seul et
qu'à ce moment ça donnerait ce genre de
choses parce que les gens seraient
laissés dans une forme de détresse il
aurait l'impression d'être enfin suez ça
ferait subi et quand on subit en général
une passe à voile et mon sentiment c'est
qu'on commence à le payer c'est un là
aussi par des modes questions que de
réponses courtes c'est un comité
scientifique
c'est un comité d'experts alors je sais
que dans ce pays quand on dit comité
d'experts on a l'impression de crânes
d'oeuf désincarné qui prennent pas le
métro cacher j'avais une baguette mais
en l'occurrence c'est un comité
d'experts s'est donc à leur industrie
écologie et 2
économie et n'essaiera de dire des
choses pas trop pilotes sur ce que le
pays peut faire fait déjà de bien
pourrait faire de mieux s'il s'agit de
respecter une trajectoire des missions
dont je le répète on va devoir la
respecte et de toute façon pour des
raisons de contraintes
d'approvisionnement un jour et bien
évidemment on aura présent à l'esprit
qui est pas de gilet jaune partout
parmi les gens chauffées au fioul parmi
les gens qui travaillent dans les
cimenteries
le président de la république a cité le
fait par exemple d'inventer des usines
du futur oui moi je trouve ça
franchement sa ventouse yade ce genre de
choses je me dis tiens mais c'est
passionnant on peut dire aussi c'est des
mots qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière
voilà vous vous sentez on peut
s'approprier ce jeu ce genre de projet
on peut surtout dire aujourd'hui que
c'est des baux et qu'on sait pas ce cas
derrière donc pour le moment
quand on dit inventé lé usine du futur
c'est son interprétation de ce qu'on va
devoir faire on aura la nôtre on est
indépendant donc on verra bien elle
travaille et je sais quand même ce que
je viens de vous dire là c'est un projet
quad on cuisine du futur louis réfléchir
aux halles usine du futur dont dans les
contraintes je vais redire une élisant
les nôtres je vais redire une évidence
pour moi mais pas suffisamment partagée
je rappelle qu'en fait l'énergie c'est
pas un truc qu'on consomme en tant que
tels les gilets jaunes sont pas
intéressés à avoir du pétrole pour le
boire donc l'énergie c'est juste quelque
chose qui permet d'utiliser une machine
donc en fait consommer de l'énergie
c'est servir de machines partir du
moment où on contracte l'énergie fossile
c'est à dire l'essentiel de l'énergie
dont on dispose on contracte le parc de
machines en fonctionnement et donc on
contracte tout le système économique le
pouvoir d'achat la reprise tout
absolument tout d'accord c'est ça qui
est titanesque dans cette affaire oui
c'est ça qui est titanesque
donc on va s'intéresser à tout donc on
peut s'intéresser en théorie à
l'aménagement du territoire à la
fiscalité à la politique des transports
à la diplomatie à la géopolitique à la
politique forestière et j'en passe et
des meilleurs donc seul le temps le
consensus entre les gens qui seront là
et les moyens qu'on aura à notre
disposition limiteront d'autres
créativité qui sera nécessairement
débridée bon on va à nous faites vous
voulez ajouter quelque chose qui ont des
projets importants
je voulais dire exactement enfin
rebondir ce qui surviendra nicheuses
paix sur le sur le fait que c'est un
élément de la solution ça ne peut pas
être tout la solution
oui parce que vous êtes obligé
effectivement de préparer la vie du non
fumeurs si je reprends le parallèle
donc ça veut dire vous êtes obligés de
planifier l'état sert quand même affaire
direct du jeu c'est comme ça son job
donc s'il faut qu'ils fassent des bonnes
mais c'est ça s'il sert pas à ça on voit
pas à quoi il sert donc et faire des
règles du jeu ça veut dire anticipé il
ya des pays dans le monde qui sont des
pays démocratiques comme les réponses un
peu variable par rapport à ce que vous
dites moi je suis d'accord avec ce que
vous ne dites pas ce que c'est la
culture de notre pays et qu'on aime bien
organiser enfin dans les pays qu'ils
aiment pas s'occuper de la vie des gens
est planifiée prenons l'exemple des
états unis c'est ce que j'allais vous
dira pas d'infrastructures quand y en a
ils sont dans un état déplorable donald
trump et président donc c'est là donc
celles au royaume du des mers de 18 mais
ça correspond pas à notre culture
oui nous on est le seul pays communistes
de l'ouest est donc en phase avec mes
donc le ce que je veux dire c'est que ça
tout ça se planifier ce anticipe donc
effectivement mettre des lignes de bus
c'est un truc que vous pouvez faire
quand il ya vraiment beaucoup de gens
concernés mètres des lignes de train
mais il en faut beaucoup plus organisés
du vélo du ces de la côte du covoiturage
en fait tout ça s'organise et à partir
du moment où les gens ou une alternative
ils sont pas plus idiot vous voulez moi
donc de temps en temps ils vont s'en
servir voulait jeter une dernière chose
non non je me rapidement je me dis que
tout ça suppose beaucoup d'argent et que
c'est pas sûr que nous en ayons beaucoup
de temps et beaucoup de volonté
l'argent plus que beaucoup d'argent non
les lignes de bus n'est pas très cher on
est en déficit en tout cas si on veut
parler argent il faut on a fait une
transition qui nous a conduits à mettre
120 milliards dans les panneaux solaires
et les éoliennes mais qui ne règle
absolument pas ce pour le l'a34 je suis
d'accord avec vous on aurait mis cet
argent depuis dix ans dans l'éradication
du fioul de chauffage parce que c'est
les mêmes mecs et chauffent au fioul et
on aurait mis ça dans la baisse de la
consommation des voitures avec des
primes à la casse intelligente on en ce
mouvement-là serait beaucoup moins
présent donc les gens qui protestent en
maîtrisant la fota macron si je vais me
permets c'est la faute à tous les
présidents qui se sont succédé depuis
qu'on a décidé de singer les allemands
sans raison valable et qu'on a décidé de
faire une transition pour antinucléaire
de centre-ville s'il reprend la
segmentation géographique dans mais
c'est exactement ça je sais droit et pas
pour type qui prend sa voiture
là où il n'y a pas d'alternative il
retient la notion de transition pour
antinucléaire de son de centre-ville et
baromètre
et le social est de retour dans ce genre
de débat et c'est tout à fait normal est
ce que ça vous inspire comme commenté
jean marc jancovici sociale oui en
regardant le reportage musée tient est
quelque chose d'intéressant c'est
commençons par la réduction de l'écart
des salaires entre les hommes et les
femmes sur les salaires j'ai quelque
chose à dire malheureusement qui est pas
une bonne nouvelle mais ça va revenir
sur ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure on a
des recettes budgétaires dans ce pays
qui sont essentiellement des impôts de
flux c'est à dire que vous prélevez
chaque année une fraction du pib qui
lui-même est influent on a peu d'impôts
de stock dans l'impôt foncier
on avait dit et c'est fort là mais sinon
c'est essentiellement des impôts de flux
le pib
je vais revenir à mon énergie tout à
l'heure c'est une façon monétaire de
compter la production économique que
vous pouvez aussi compter en
kilowattheures ce que l'énergie c'est la
marque une transformation et l'économie
consiste à transformer des ressources
naturelles ans à sa faim voilà quand
vous avez moins d'énergie je disais tout
à l'heure on a moins de transformation
quand vous avez moins de transformation
vous avez moins de pib toutes choses
égales par ailleurs si vous avez moins
de pib vous avez moins de recettes
budgétaires donc la très mauvaise
nouvelle et ça aussi c'est quelque chose
qui était prévisible avec cette lecture
de l'économie sans vouloir me vanter les
liens certain nombre de fois monsieur
macron va devoir faire un choix car le
gouvernement la france parce que la
limite le destin me suis marré on s'en
fiche on parle du pays bon la
collectivité et va devoir s'organiser
avec des moyens en contraction
face à des problèmes qui augmente oui
voilà jossart me craignaient nous
expliquer cette année donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui malheureusement alors
là où je veux pas être d'accord avec lui
c'est que dans ce contexte la toux
décentralisée moi je crois que c'est pas
une bonne idée parce que quand on
décentralise on prend la liberté mais on
prend aussi l'absence de filet de
sécurité
d'accord c'est le mrd vous retrouvez
centrale il a donc ses lacets la
désolidarisation tapez pas forcément pas
forcément une vision radicale est très
marquée que vous avez là mais pas
forcément ça dépend lons us en avoir
mais ça dépend de vous je répète en
sorte de siège de croissance donc ce que
les pays ont fait dans un contexte en
croissance et un bon vin en perte de
croissance et pas de mauvais manager
donc ce que les pays ont fait en période
de croissance n'est pas nécessairement
reproductible sur ce qu'on est capable
de faire en période de contraction
c'est pas c'est pas les mêmes
contraintes c'est donc pour en revenir à
cette doxa d'il ya un arbitrage à faire
s'est recueilli à des cas de figure où
la centralisation et contre-productive
il ya des cas de figure où la
décentralisation est contre-productive
voilà donc sur les salaires je le redis
on ne peut c'est compliqué à partir du
moment où il ya un facteur limitant qui
s'applique à l'économie qui n'est pas un
facteur humain c'est pas le nombre de
gens qui travaillent la complaisance des
banquiers qui est un facteur physique la
production parce que la terre fait 13 8
kilomètres de diamètre aujourd'hui comme
il ya deux siècles n'a pas changé et
bien à ce moment vous ne pouvez
redistribuer donc les salaires en font
partie que ce que une partie de ce que
vous avez produit taillé à mon avis le
vrai sujet il est - l'augmentation des
salaires dans hors contexte que la part
entre les salaires et des rentes donc
moi je pense que le vrai débat dans un
monde contre 1 c'est celui de delà de la
du distinguo entre les salaires et les
rentes je suis pas sûr que ce débat
aujourd'hui sur treize adultes qu il n
osait transformer les colères aux
solutions sont des mots magnifiques on
ne peut pas ne pas être d'accord et en
même temps on a envie de lui dire
comment vous avez compris la méthode
vous moi je comprends que c'est
l'expression en paradoxalement d'un
désarroi c'est à dire qu'ils répondent à
désarroi de la rue par son propre
désarroi depuis chirac en fait on a des
présidents qui sont formatés pour
conquérir le pouvoir qu'ils savent plus
quoi en faire une fois qu'ils sont au
pouvoir c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas
d'objet ils n'ont pas de récit l'ont pas
de narratif ils disent pas tiens on va
aller sur la lune
alors il aurait pu dire lui avec son mec
de planet green moi c'était mon souhait
bas nous les français on a un plan un
peu mégalo un peu ambitieux un peu
délirant on va décarbonés l'économie
nous on va le faire et les autres ne
font pas nous on va le faire et ça c'est
un objet donc dans décarbonés l'économie
je change les bâtiments je change les
villes je change l'agriculture
changement un peu ce qu'il a dit la
première partie de son intervention il
l'a dit il sait toujours pas comment le
faire donc ils pensent que en passant le
relais des dites donc avec votre comité
se réunit une fois par mois dans
attendait faut pas trop en demander à
trop dépenser politique
c'est fait polytechnique pour rien avec
l'argent du contribuable a laissé
théodule ça c'est vrai merci mais je
travaille un tiers de mon temps de
manière bénévole la sphère de lui rendre
comme ça me reprocher bon ben c'est bien
donc le donc je pense qu'il est juste en
train de passer la charge de la preuve à
des gens qui n'appartient pas c'est à
dire qu'on fait
enfin moi je suis pas politologue mais
je je j'ai l'impression un peu
intuitivement comme ça que cette
manifestation la fiscalité n'est qu'un
prétexte
au fond il ya la raison de fond est
beaucoup plus profonde
c'est un sentiment que je sais pas où je
vais parce que quand vous avez un cap un
peu difficile à passer
oui là vous allez à peut transpirer la
courir le 100 m vous avez pas envie mais
derrière vous savez que vous avez une
bonne bouffe
bon ben vous le faites non mais là on
est dans le cas de figure dans lequel on
va vous dire on va vous mettre la tête
sous l'eau froide capot on vous dit pas
ce qui se passe à l'horizon les pâtes
les voilà alors je le dis plus mais il
ya quelque chose il ya quelque chose de
ça pour moi et donc on a besoin d'un art
hâtif on a besoin de quelqu'un qui nous
disent voilà on est en regrette d'avoir
dit oui de trois ans comme ça et donc on
a besoin de quelqu'un qui nous disent
voilà l'horizon il est là puis on va y
aller tous ensemble c'est parce qu'il a
fait ce matin en fait vous voulez
emmanuel churchill un peu on met mais je
pense qu'on est dans une situation de
crise profonde larvée elle et elle est
pas aussi brutale que l'invasion d'un
pays par l'allemagne mais il ya quelque
chose on est dans la tectonique des
plaques aujourd'hui c'est à dire que les
trucs sont en train de se mettre en
tension puis temps en temps ça pète puis
la sec le début je vous le dis parce que
l'énergie ayant tout fait dans notre
monde de l'énergie ayant tout fait dans
votre monde
la décrue énergétique c'est la
tectonique des plaques qui met tout en
tension
bon donc tout bon donc le si on s'occupe
pas du problème il est dangereuse il va
s'occuper de nous et aujourd'hui il n'ya
pas donc c'est ça que je voulais dire
dans la décentralisation peut pas de
décentraliser le narratif c'est ça je
voulais dire on peu décentralisés
d'actions décentralisées des moyens en
neutralisation c'est du narratif
oui d'accord mais on peut dire voilà le
jeu auquel on va jouer et une partie des
règles du jeu vont être fait au plus
près du terrain ça évidemment je suis
d'accord avec ça mais le jeu dans son
ensemble chacun peut pas inventer la
règle du jeu de son côté parlé
tectonique des plaques ça mais une
question c'est est ce qu'on est en train
d'assister à une nouvelle forme de
je sais pas s'il faut dire de révolution
c'est un thermique ces sites mais qui
est celle d'une partie des classes
moyennes louis désocialisés c'est ceux
qui sont montés avec le pétrole et ceux
qui sont en train de descendre avec la
décrue du pétrole denis crenn le moins
possible jean marc jancovici
vraiment je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ça en fait on a besoin d'un plan
c'est mais au bon sens du terme au bon
sens du terme c'était là qu'on a besoin
de nommer un objet de dire comment on y
va de dire comment on partage l'effort
de dire qu'il y aura des efforts de dire
qu'il y aura des joies aussi parce que
c'est pas faire un truc ne faisait pas
juste de la peine et je vais finir par
quelque chose car rien à voir avec le
gilet jaune mais qui va vous montrer que
pour moi c'est vraiment une perte de
sens
il ya les étudiants de grandes écoles
qui ont lancé il n'ya pas longtemps un
manifeste pour un réveil écologique
ça fait un carton et ce truc là dit on
veut pas juste fabriquer des bouteilles
de coca cola aurait du sens en gros je
vous la fais très courte mais c'est ça
donc je pense qu on est vraiment en
train d'assister à quelque chose qui
transcende sas incarne de façon très
diverses
donc les uns vont dire je n'arrive pas à
faire le plein mais moi je pense qu'il
ya profondément une quête de sens et
macron il n'a pas de chance c'est celui
dont je suis d'accord c'est celui qui a
rendez vous avec l'histoire
pas de pot pour lui c'est lui qui bat en
croissance pardon oui m et justement
aujourd'hui ces passants dans paris
c'est ça son problème